how are you coach Goodrich how're you
doing I'm doing fine your your team's
being very hyped coach I don't know why
we haven't done anything well you won
the division last year and you you look
terrific and doing it and many people
thought that you had that playoff game
you know all lined up for yourself you
know so yeah absolutely no we it was a
it was a good year for us we created a
culture that you know the guys love
coming to work and we had a lot of fun
and but then we ended with that that
tough loss at home to Philly and and you
know we're we use that in the offseason
to remind us of where we were but we're
it's good to put that behind us now and
get rolling here with the rookies being
here in the last couple of days it's and
then that that's coming tomorrow we're
really excited and so what what I asked
this question of Sean Payton yesterday
I'll ask it of you what is the plan what
do you get out of training camp what
when you go insane when we break camp I
want X to happen what do you got for me
on that front so last year we thought it
was worse was you know really learning
who each other was how we do what we do
offensively defensively all that was
kind of new building that culture and
trying to become calloused as well we
wanted to we had some nice live periods
in training camp where we could kind of
control everything and I think that's
where we're at this year as well now I
know I know all these players inside I
don't mind you guys I've known pretty
well and at least you know the top the
first first group second group guys that
we have I know what their hot buns are I
know when they be pushed when they don't
need push when we need to pull back and
they don't mind as well and so the
second year starting up for us you know
some changes to this camp schedules that
we've done last year and just to help us
out and what the best part about
training camp is you can put the pads on
you can go you know as much as you want
live and it's all controlled so I think
that's the beauty of it you can
condition your guys through plays and
through practice get a test to where
they're a so that you're ready to rock
and roll I'm we born well we always
talked about improving year one a year
two and year to two year three etc
etcetera or what it's year two to three
in terms of reality
for your quarterback but it's from year
one a year two with you and your
quarterback what are your expectations
from it's true Biscay in 2019 so we're
kind of talking about it as a team right
now
you know steady incremental improvement
and for him that's a day-to-day thing
and she's done a phenomenal job in this
offseason at being able to recognize
some of the things that he's seeing on
the defensive side last year he saw it
he could see the defenses and trying to
place it into how we we call our
offensive plays and where to go with the
football but it doesn't it just doesn't
happen overnight and so now he's got
this full library of plays that we both
know me as a play caller the plays that
he likes him as a as a player the plays
that that he likes we fit it together
and now we put it against the defense
and so the defense is that you've seen
in OTAs and what he's about to see in
training camp appreciation hopefully the
game will slow down for them and that
that will increase his you know his
anticipation with throws where he's
going with the ball and I can already
tell these last couple days in rookie
camp just his rhythm and how calm he is
in the pocket it's cool to see well what
about the idea of him taking off I mean
how many times we see quarterbacks get
hurt on that front the names Garoppolo
and went sleep to mind what do you tell
him about that yeah so we dealt a little
bit with that in Kansas City with Alex
and youth Alex was a sneaky good runner
and so we never want to take that away
from him because I've I've talked a lot
of defensive coaches in the league you
know that they're scared to death of
that that element of the legs of being
able to get a first down on third down
that can just break in and trick me and
keep a drive going and so but we we got
to be smart with it and he's done a
pretty good job with that he knows how
to slide not every quarterback knows on
his life Mitch does and and I think the
biggest thing with Mitch is he's a tough
kid so he's not afraid to take a hit but
you got to be smart and you got to get
down he's too important to us and we
lost him last year after a hit and the
Vikings game for a couple weeks and so
hopefully he learns from that we learned
from that don't put up in all those
situations bears head coach Matt Negi
joining us before veteran's report on
Friday for bears training camp walk me
through the running back situation here
David Montgomery has been added
in the third round out of Oklahoma State
and man was he productive there Mike
Davis now from the Seattle I guess
triple headed monster that they had to
Rico man
Cohen we know what he can do how is this
all going to be divvied up based on your
idea
yeah we're fired up about you know where
we're at right now and they're with the
running back room you know you said at
first with David Montgomery it was hard
to put the tape down to him watching him
and all his plays in his career at Iowa
State that how hard the kid runs I mean
he's starving right now to put these
pads on he's been asking and keeps
bothering me about coach one can we put
these pads on he wants to get out there
and just and hit people and he's done a
great job in the past game so far they
know TAS and then what a super kid just
he's all he cares about is football and
he just wants to help us win and Mike
Davis coming over from Seattle was a
great free agent acquisition for us with
somebody that picked up our offense
already he knows it inside out I can do
multiple things both in the run and pass
game and another great teammate and then
obviously Tariq Owen he's there as well
so you know he's he's a guy that can
just he makes you a better a better
football coach he makes me a better
football coach I know what you can do
with them so to be able to use Adobe
Tom's or all three of them are on the
field at the same time and we can do
some some fun things with it and I just
I really love with where we're at right
now but who's got the bell cow you know
when it's 20 degrees out what do you
what do you do there yeah well we'll
find out we'll find out you know we got
another guy to I think you know who we
picked up and he's about six foot three
230 pounds and he's not scared to run
the ball up the middle either and got
from got him from New England and so
Cordero's a pretty good ball carrier too
so well-well we'll do some different
things and and have some fun back there
for that Bell cow so Bella checks not
the only guy that uses him like that is
what you're saying yeah
no we're gonna we're gonna have fun with
him that's going to be that's going to
be we can't get too crazy but we got it
we got to be able to have fun and the
guy has has done a lot of good things
from the backfield as a wide receiver
out wide and obviously special teams
goes without saying Matt naggy bears
head coach here on the Rich Eisen show
Chuck Pagano is one of my favorite
people on planet Earth
Matt that I have met in my 16 plus years
so I asked this with that respect
upfront Vic Fangio not there is really
scaring a lot of bears fans and how he
was able to turn the defense up another
notch Khalil Mack certainly helped on
that front what can you tell bears fans
about the defensive side of the ball
with Fangio now getting his shot for the
first time and in Denver well to me
number one bigs gonna doing a great job
in Denver I'm so happy for him to get
that opportunity to be a head coach and
I learned a lot from him last year and
just weekly do these responsibilities
how to handle players and then he's
accused of brilliant brilliant defensive
coach and just really knows things
inside out is great scheming and and so
but what I think is so neat about you
know football in general or sports in
general is there's so many different
flavors and different styles of coaches
and there's so many great coaches out
there so when it comes down to it it's
all about the players and what we do but
Chuck like you said I mean I did not
know Chuck going into the interview
process huh it took me 10 minutes not
within the process to realize that this
is my type of guy and it that every
single day that we're together I'm just
so excited that we lose Vic Fangio to a
promotion the players have built three
to four good years with with Coach
Fangio learning his scheme and what he
does and they had a lot of success and
that's what's so neat but now Chuck
knows I mean this is he knows he's
coming into a defense a team that has
high expectations and I just love the
fact that you came into this thing with
with let's bring it on mentality that
that's what he wants he understands that
and you know him as a person like you
said this guy doesn't care I mean he's
he's happy-go-lucky every moment of the
day
he's a player's coach meaning that he
pushes on but he loves them he has fun
he fits our culture and I'm just I'm
really looking forward to seeing what he
does with these guys and there's going
to be highs and lows that's with
everything but I have a lot of
confidence in coach Coach McDonald all
right let's move to a little bit
an omnibus portion of our conversation
here coach Matt naggy
first things first pass interference now
being challengeable now you can review
this stuff but you throw a flag to say
hey my my offensive player got interfere
dwith it's possible they go under the
hood and say guess what your offensive
player is the one who shoved off I'm
wondering what your philosophy is on
throwing a challenge flag for this is
going to be this fall yeah well I'm all
for it I think that you know it's it is
a difficult job right now for the
officials to go out there and make
there's a lot of different calls that
can be made but you know I I do agree
that obviously everyone goes back to the
RAM Saints game and you know we all we
all don't want to see that happened
again but it's it's trying to get things
right and so as a for us and I know most
coaches as we talked in the offseason
you have to be judicial with how you use
deciding on when you're going to use use
your challenge and I think what you're
gonna end up seeing is there's going to
be some times early in the you know in
the first half where there might be some
great calls or some times where you
might want to say man I really want to
challenge it but you really can't and
and I'm okay with that
or if you think it is for sure and you
want to use it you know you're going to
win you feel 100 percent then then you
keep that challenge and you'll have it
for later in the game but you just don't
want to get now that you have the
ability to challenge it and put a flag
on the field you don't want to be caught
in the situation where you don't have it
because you use there early in the game
that's my opinion okay your quarterback
do you call him Mitch or Mitchell what
do you choose you know what I try every
other day to me so today today we're on
a mid state tomorrow Mitchell okay very
good
did you know did you know he had the
chugging of the beer in him because that
was a very NFC North quarterback
competition thing that happened you know
I I never saw it firsthand but when I
did see it I wasn't surprised at all
right so you thought he had that in him
is basically what you're saying he
pushed her yeah okay I did you know he's
a he's a he's an Ohio guy and I'm a PA
guy and has thought these guys they're
they know it's uh that didn't shock me
one bit okay does he call you Matt or
Matthew what does he call you on those
days he calls me coach that's one way to
put it I like that
Otis spent a day at Wrigley Field coach
and it looks like you painted the black
on your ceremonial first pitch or do you
have some baseball background you know
what rich I do III did stop playing my
junior year of high school I was a
centerfielder and a pitcher but it's
it's totally different when you're up
there on top of that mound and they tell
you to aim high so last year when I
threw the first pitch at dirt or one in
the in the by the mound I refused me by
the home plate my kids just crushed me
for for a whole year and so I went out
there and I was able to throw a strike
and you know they say it's 68 miles per
hour my elbow felt like it was gonna
fall off but I'll take it I was
definitely there's a lot worse out there
so I was happy with and then you did
take me out to the ball game is there
anything you'd care to clarify about
that the lyrics
unbelievable I'll tell you what so I
have this northeast accent that just I'm
getting crushed for right now it is what
it is my players already knew about it
just because we talked about some ice
cream toppings that we do on Saturday
night the hotel and different types of
toppings that we put on the ice cream so
they always laughed at me all year for
that that said that they thought that
when you said peanuts you were saying
something else is that what you say as
well they did you know and they crushed
me all year and and I should have known
I got to be better prepared I should
have known going into that yeah out to
the ballgame that that word is in there
and that's a complete failure your
players giving you so much grief I'm
telling you right now I guarantee you
one of these coaches is gonna try to put
that up in front of a TV if I find out
who it is they get fired
fantastic you also gave a commencement
address at the University of Delaware
that's your own mater correct
yeah the blue headband the blue head is
and you said you were gonna come up with
a specific play call called a second
chicken correct which is a reference to
the blue hen in a way correct that's
right yeah yeah we're were its I think
anytime you get asked to give a
commencement speech and then you get an
honorary Doctorate so now my wife save
what I call me doc to see you know call
me a doctor
I get that and so now I got to give back
to Delaware and we just got to get a
play in there for the ass-kicking
chicken so it's I have an idea what it's
going to be I haven't told one single
person on staff but once once it comes
out we'll let you know okay
so we'll see in it it's a scoring plays
what you promised the good people yeah
it's only that yeah all right so is it
just for them or can I request a Rich
Eisen show play call we'll get it in
okay I think it should just be called
you know the Rich Eisen show that's what
it should be called because I'm branding
every opportunity and it should I'm
shipping it included least two laterals
can I do that - two laterals yes of
sorts okay yeah all right well we we can
do that I can't promise you a score but
I can we can get it in there and and and
and for sure we will I'll make sure that
I declare when it's being called that's
correct
I appreciate that last one for you coach
and this is personal for me okay and
also my god Chris Brockman is across the
way when you come in here in person
you'll you'll meet him and you'll notice
we're both follically challenged quite
like yes okay I'm concerned for you that
you is a follically challenged man go go
Weiser you go Weiser and you're leaving
yourself completely unprotected to the
elements and I'm wondering this is
clearly a choice this is not something
that just happens clearly you were
making a choice why are you doing that
coach because it not only leaves you
unprotected I gotta mention it also
accentuates as well as why do you do
this may I ask so you know I just fought
in Kansas City I was aware advisor and
as I got here I just you know I started
wearing it earlier on it and I think we
won a couple ballgames and there's a
little bit of superstition behind it but
now I'm like you know it's now because I
get asked that question now I just do it
it just feels right it's just it's the
way to go and I kind of like being
different and that to mediate I guess
that's that's different but that's yeah
lots of sunscreen yeah which is which is
great and then you know I got that
people forget that when you're calling
play
you got the headset on in 20-degree
weather and Soldier Field you're as long
as my ears are protected I'm good and so
you know that's it's pretty simple it's
it's it's work and I'm gonna keep it
going there cuz a large percentage of
your body heat escapes from the top of
your head it's like five degrees out and
you're just still letting your freak
flag fly like that and I'm sitting there
well I'm impressed but I'm also
concerned I'm not gonna lie
well I appreciate for both you should
try just try it one time and just see I
mean it's really not that bad Oh what
the visor a visor with try the visor
yeah you know wow I don't even know I
don't even know if I have that in me I
gotta be honest it's a bold move I have
the same amount of success that clearly
you have had with it I might have to
give it a try how does that sound I
appreciate that yeah you need to for
sure what the center send me the visors
I will wear the visors and you Institute
the Rich Eisen show play two laterals
and the last lateral has to go to the
slowest guy on the team take care of
yourself coach always enjoy your alright
thank you take care Amanda you bet
that's a Matt naggy your reigning coach
of the year in the National Football
League for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app